jusque là épargné l'ouest de l'ukraine
et est désormais aussi exposé aux
bombardements russes on va faire un
point tout de suite avec notre envoyé
spécial à lviv du livreur crack bonjour
gulliver d'abord quelle est la situation
dans la région et comment est-ce qu'on
réagit sur place
alors ce matin nous avons eu des
déclarations du gouverneur de la région
maxime qu est ce qui est du maire de
vivonne drissa dovi maxime candide qui
est dans une conférence de presse dans
le bâtiment derrière moi qui devenu un
centre pour les très très très nombreux
journalistes à être j'ai à présent à
lviv qui a ouvert aujourd'hui il a
surtout voulu souligner que sur cette
attaque sur la base des yavo rives il
n'y a pas eu parmi les victimes des
combattants étrangers il a dit que la
russie tente et de propager de fausses
informations en ce sens il a voulu
souligner que ce procès en conformation
ce n'était absolument pas le cas il a
continué pour dire qu'il voudrait que
les organisations en aide internationale
les grandes ong internationales se
mobilisent plus rapidement pour venir
ici à lviv et à d'autres endroits dans
l'ouest de l'ukraine pour aider avec
l'effort humanitaire pour les très
nombreux déplacés qui sont ici il a dit
que pour le moment c'est les
collectivités locales les volontaires
qui portent l'essentiel du poids de ses
très très très grand nombre de déplacés
qu'il faudrait vraiment que les
organisations internationales
humanitaires venditti il a continué
aussi en réclamant comme le fait le
président volodymyr zelensky à chaque
opportunité cette zone d'exclusion
aérienne au dessus de l'ukraine de
l'otan ou à défaut de cela d'autres
formes d'aidés internationales à
l'ukraine selon le gouverneur régional
l'aide internationale à l'ukraine vient
bien trop lentement culliver en mode
c'est pour parler on en parlait en titre
pourparlers qui se poursuivent
aujourd'hui entre chrétiens et et russe
sans grand espoir
oui vous savez parmi les gens à qui j'ai
parlé il n'y a vraiment pas beaucoup
d'espoir mm il ya une forme de crainte
que si jamais cette c'est le feu ils
gagnent cela pourrait être en réalité
juste utilisé par les russes pour se
regrouper pour mieux planifier leurs
prochaines attaques ou encore pour
attaquer sur le front informationnel sur
le crâne et essayé de diffuser de
fausses informations et de briser cette
unité nationale en terme d'opinion
publique il semble y avoir pour le
moment derrière l'ukraine donc les
icaunais ne sont même pas sûr que ce
serait une bonne chose si les russes
semblent déclaré une spéciale feu le
niveau de confiance en la russie est
vraiment extrêmement bas et pour cause
quand on voit les cibles comment les
infrastructures steve hill est
clairement visé tous les jours par les
pistons des villes quand mario paul à
arqués 20e et d'innombrables aussi un
petit village et villes à travers toute
l'ukraine centrale du sud et de l'est
c'est vraiment uniquement l'ouest
maintenant qu'ils étaient pas renié les
attaques sur les civils merci gulliver
craque pour ce point envoyé spécial lviv
dans l'ouest de l'ukraine demain